cast IRL will be live in Miami with
Patrick Bet David Donald Trump Jr Matt
Gates and Luke gradkowski join us there
get your tickets by clicking the link in
the description below or by going to
timcast.com Brian Kemp declares a state
of emergency in Georgia over inflation
quote all bidenomics has done is take
more money out of the pockets of the
middle class Kemp said I don't get this
guy's deal it's like he hates Trump but
he hates buying what's what's he
intending what's his what's his what's
his intended outcome here or it's simple
enough to say the economy is Joe
Biden's at fault and no one can deny it
I think it's probably that he you know
he's well actually I don't know when is
he up for re-election
is it next year I have no idea
because I think the reelection could be
a thing because if he's he is a
republican even though he's not a Maga
Republican if I understand correctly
um and that being the case if he is up
for re-election next year he
doesn't want to risk being you know
opposed to the uh the Republican nominee
Donald Trump and and it's probably a
smart uh smart thing to do if you're a
republican yeah he suspended their gas
tax
really yeah
what about the roads
he won in 2022
Brian Kemp so does that mean he's gonna
he was a four-year term I don't know the
economy is kind of shitty and uh it's
been shitty for some time and it feels
like it's just a bunch of paper stacked
on top of paper
I'm I'm I'm wondering uh how the
Democrats think they're gonna win with
ailing Joe Biden with a up
economy and it's not up in the
sense that like everyone can clearly see
that the machine is broken it's
up and like it is a piece it's like
imagine a sheet with a bunch of holes
punched through it like someone hung up
a sheet and then start shooting at it
with a full auto rifle of some sort and
so we can we can clearly see this
thing's full of holes burned sayings and
will not function as a sheet but some
people are like well the area that I'm
using seems to be okay and that's the so
that's the weird thing as we move
forward in 2024 how do the Democrats
expect to win if you've got
a a crippled economy and an ailing old
man who can't remember where the he
is yeah it might it doesn't work my
guess is the war they'll use the
Ukrainian War to try and be like can't
change presidents during a war yeah
that's uh that's what a lot of people
typically say I just don't quite know
how well that's going to go because
we're not at War and I mean that's sort
of the thing when they make all the
treason not right now yeah true that but
it's like when they make the whole
treason comments in regards to anybody
that poses to wish like I mean that that
can't even work we're not technically
you know combatants there right uh
technically no well we're not um
technically not legally I don't think so
uh I mean we are but you know like
technically did you see the Ukrainian I
don't know if it's propaganda Minister
but they're speaking in English it's
like their English translator saying
that they will hunt down people that
have made Russian like pro-russian
propaganda on the internet I don't know
if they're saying like hey by the way
we're gonna try and come kill Americans
that have talked about Ukraine
during this conflict they got enough
migrants and refugees into uh possibly
make that happen right but there's a lot
of people that are that are bummed out
with uh people like Hinkle and like uh
that uh other big uh monkey or a big
gorilla looking dude the uh the dude at
the beard the infrared guy I don't know
what his name he's uh I know the Maga
Communists he's the big he's the big
dude with the big beard the Maga
communist guy oh guys here what you guys
here no no the other guy oh okay the big
thumbs up
communist victim you know what the hell
is communism yeah there's people who are
like somehow both a trump supporter and
a communist which doesn't really make
sense no and I think it's actually born
of ignorance yeah like well Communists
are dumb to begin with yeah they they're
not it is it is you almost communism is
probably three percent intelligent
individuals trying to manipulate a group
of people for political power and then
97 first order thinkers who have no idea
what the they're talking about or
where food comes from True Believers and
so they just March and locks that behind
the priestesses and Priests of their
cult and just do as they're told and I
gotta imagine that the three percent are
totally willing to turn on each other
when they get power 100 absolutely if
you look at what Stalin did he just
murked do you think Stalin poisoned and
killed Lenin uh I mean I don't know I I
don't know and I don't I don't really
have a feeling either way they're both
awful so it's kind of you know London
just got sick and died all of a sudden
and then Stalin was like all right I
guess I'm in charge now I mean I know he
killed a lot of people that were behind
him like the people lower than him on
the rungs I know I don't know if he
killed uh Lennon to get into into his
position but you know the uh like
Khrushchev was when exposed all of
Stalin's crimes
so I don't understand how people
actually call themselves you know
stalinists nowadays yeah that's crazy
look like the Khrushchev literally told
the whole like all of the Soviets it was
a it was a late at night see uh secret
speech it was called and he went and and
it was he talked about the cult of
personality and how Marx was like
he said that Marx had told them to not
get involved in Cult of Personality
stuff and that's what made Stalin so
powerful is he the people were actually
kind of worshiping him and you know he's
slaughtering Russians all the time
killing ukrainians
um and Khrushchev admitted it Khrushchev
was like this is what happened you know
and and that was part of why the Soviet
Union started to have some kind of uh
opening up and the the actual
you know the murders and stuff started
to end it came to a close because Stalin
was no longer in power and Khrushchev
admitted what he did but still bringing
that back to Georgia's economy though do
you think
um I mean when it comes to Brian Kim do
you think that he just expects a
Republican party to just be in a
wreckage after they go after Trump and
for him and whatever his new breed and
neocons to just basically pick up
afterwards and you know kind of these
people are insane Brian like
Republicans have always been The
Underdogs relative to Democrats there's
two parties Republicans are smaller
Republicans win when they would convince
Independence that's it but many of these
people were already like
democrat-leaning individuals and they
had to pull really hard
if these people think they're going to
muster up anything when Trump has built
a a better and bigger Coalition right
they're out of their minds well
they even I hate these people yeah
they've always been nuts I mean these
were the same people in that thought
that if they just got rid of Saddam
Hussein in Iraq that also but
Iraqi Exile I might Ahmed chalabi in
there and you know everything will run
as normal because apparently Shiites you
know love Jordanian blood or some crazy
stuff like they've never understood you
know people and you know they've
literally screwed up every opportunity
they had to overtake the Democrats so
I I don't know if they they they're
planning this or they just suck at
calibrating I I'm still not sure which
one it is the Republican party you're
talking about yeah well it's not a model
I think yes but neocons actually to be
to be
exactly yep
I'm all for someone you know starting
their own thing but I don't know man
party Party Loyalty
when we start talking Party Loyalty is
when my I start to get but that's why
that's what what happened it broke
Democrats are losing the younger
generation Republicans are losing the
younger generation and that's why you
see leftist populists and right-wing
populists now I happen to think that the
left-wing populists are mostly just
first order thinkers like I said you're
relatively ignorant people who don't pay
attention and the challenge we've we're
faced with is you know you've got like
anti-communist libertarian over here
Phil who can tell you all about this
stuff he's researched why he feels the
way he does and then if philos have an
argument with one of these liberals
they're going to be like no no and it's
like okay like there's no conversation
to be had it happens I tell people I'm
all the time I'm like look we're
actually in the middle we're going
through a cultural revolution it's
slower here in the U.S than it was in
China but we're going through one here
and it's a lot like what happened in
China constantly people like no we're
not what are you talking about you're
crazy all the while
out in California I just the other day I
was I retweeted something one of the
again it's it was an on the ground like
uh activist you know organizer kind of
person straight up communist we're
Communists like there was no no balking
no no parsing words we're Communists
straight up if you're gonna go ahead and
announce we're Communists you are an
enemy of the country because you are an
enemy of the principles that our
country's founded on how yeah go ahead
I'm gonna say how we got to the point
where the 1964 Civil Rights Act exempts
human rights to Communists to the point
where now people are waving communist
Flags
I'm not saying people have the Communist
persuasion should be Not Human Rights
I'm just saying we that's a huge shift
we should at least be like hey it's not
okay to be a communist like yes you can
believe that stuff it's like I'm not
gonna I'm not gonna stop you from eating
at a restaurant because you're a
communist but we're not voting for you
we will criticize you and we will shun
you just like Nazis yes they're just
like Nazis people and swastika it's like
the same thing to me they both there's
evil sub evil signals let's just get rid
of them absolutely I could not agree any
more than I do the the idea that that
Communists are somehow unacceptable uh
or communism is somehow an acceptable
type of of organism Organization for
your Society is ridiculous you have to
brainwash people but you don't have you
can't allow people to say I don't want
to if you're in a communist Society but
the problem is communism and Nazism by
you know just their core philosophy
those are in stage sort of you know okay
we screwed up guys type movements so the
system has to be broken up and it has to
be to a point where one side can't
govern in order for one to take hold
with Nazism is because again you know
after uh you know yeah after Weimar
Germany after literally Churchill kept
the blockade in place for eight months
and they were starving and they signed
that horrible treaty it was like
everybody was pissed and he went and
then Wilson wouldn't even let the
military sign it so they were pissed off
that's how they got Nazism whereas again
with um you know communism it was the
fact that Wilson went ahead and bribed
the you know karinsky and his
revolutionary government to stay in the
war long after they were well done with
it and they were going to say hey we'll
end it as is and they stayed in the war
and basically ruined their whole economy
and then that's what led Lenin both of
these things are when the system breaks
down which is where they're trying to
drive the United States to so they can
be they can be like the The Shining
Bastion of this big light of like all
this truth and Order and Etc and they've
got expiration dates yeah yeah exactly
dude I was just reading about this
karensky guy you mentioned Alexander
karinsky and he was the head of the
provincial Russian government there's a
short-lived Russian Republic so so the
Empire there's a Revolt a republican
reform for three months and then that
was overthrown by the Bolsheviks yes
that was what time yeah that was what
allowed the because again he he
kept the war going he took all of the
like uh it was like a 350 million dollar
loan from the United States there was
all these extra guns boots and weapons
that were shipped there and they were
ready in the world war one if they would
end World War one right there again the
Germans had already came to an agreement
with the French they were going to lay
down their arms they were going to say
okay you know what it is what it is
we're done but instead they kept it
going and then after the Germans lay
down their arms wisdom Churchill kept
the blockade in place starving uses used
it as leverage to drive them to sign a
terrible treaty and then split Germany
up which gave rise to Hitler and stolen
came off the backs of linen exactly and
so literally Wilson he screwed he gave
us the whole Nazis versus Kami Singh
that's how those ideas
I wonder if in 100 years they're going
to be saying things like
the United States was pressing their
their military Alliance in Europe up
against the border of Russia Russia kept
saying don't do this to violation of the
treaties we had in the past and then
when Russia tried having a peace
agreement the West sent in one of their
Prime Ministers to break that up which
eventually led to the assassination of
diplomats so and so in in Poland which
sparked a wave and then Joe Biden
declared war and you know yep yeah
thanks for watching this clip from the
timcast IRL podcast hang out with us
live Monday through Friday at 8 pm and
become a member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time